et bien clément gignac vice président
principal économiste en chef à
l'industrielle alliance
clément gignac bonsoir bonsoir alors
chute du pib en mars 2 9% chute jusqu'à
73 % au deuxième trimestre en rythme
annualisé selon la banque du canada
c'est quand même spectaculaire ces
chiffres définitivement parce que vous
savez de basket devrait première fois
présent maintenant deux scénarios un
scénario optimiste et pessimiste et un
peu plus tôt ce matin et 27,6 qu'un but
qui donnait les données du mois de mars
et où au cours du uniquement du mois de
mars gerald le pib l'activité économique
a chuté de 9% au canada donc c'est du
jamais vu depuis continué sept cycles
depuis début des années 60 et ça augure
la queue au deuxième trimestre sa beauté
quand même très bon premier trimestre
une baisse de 10% est annuelle et on
parle que ça pourrait aussi en 40 et 60%
comme vous dîtes le on essaie de
conscience que ça veut dire parce qu'on
est écrit en bas d'écran une chute du
pib de 73%
ça c'est l'extrême la de la projection
de la banque du canada l'économie
complètement arrêtée là vraiment
vraiment juste pour visualiser pour les
jeunes c'est comme si on veut tourné
vingt ans en arrière c'est vrai comme le
niveau d'activité économique en vain
mais en recul au début de l'an 2000 donc
c'est comme son effet c'est important
parce que c'est un de ces temporaires ce
qu'on vit là évidemment pour parler de
la reprise mais confirme l'économie et
s'amène qu'on en ait fait ce printemps
d'activité économique donc c'est
considérable de quoi sens rythmique
droite était donc ça veut dire un taux
de chômage qui doit être assez élevé
évidemment au deuxième trimestre et ça
veut dire quoi quand la banque du canada
dit si ça dure longtemps il y aurait des
problèmes structurels dans l'économie
mais je fais une comparaison quand on
parle infrastructures générales on parle
souvent les viaducs les bambins dans
l'économie c'est un peu demain faut voir
ce long des entreprises qui sont là bas
il faut qu'il soit encore là ces
entreprises là lorsque l'économie va
reprendre kobo peut-être retrouver
médicaments pour soigner son taux
malades ou éventuellement le vaccin donc
il faut vraiment qu'on y aille avec des
mesures pour que dans le fond que on
peut savoir ce fait que l'intervention
c'est que les travailleurs peut savoir
de l'argent peut se manger s'alimenter
vives et les entreprises soient encore
là de boules donc pour la banque du
canada
si on dure très longtemps qu'on ferme
l'économie trop longtemps mais là ça va
amener des problèmes structurels passera
mais défait de l'entreprise et même ça
va fragiliser notre secteur bancaire
avec tout ça on sait que le déficit
fédéral soit majeur on ne parle là
quelques reprises ensemble
la banque du canada va maintenant
racheter des obligations provinciales
est ce qu'on comprend qu'il est
difficile des provinces seront aussi
très importants
oui on est très élevé en fait une des
raisons pourquoi qui ont fait se sont
fait un peu tirer l'oreille girel mes
passions je mène préfecture lorsque
j'étais à te voir 2008 2010 on ne manque
pas fait ça donc c'est parce que
terre-neuve et l'alberta avait des
problèmes à pouvoir emprunter et qui
plus est le prime de risque qu'ils
devaient payer jusqu'à 150 points 200
points de base c'est un nid à 2% de plus
que ce que paient le gouvernement
fédéral pour emprunter ces marchés or
ils n'ont pas besoin d'avoir des taux
d'intérêt plus élevés au congrès vote
des taux des dreads plus bas donc
difficulté emprunté et primes de risque
très élevé et se devait d'intervenir
même le québec l'ontario ont payé plus
cher que normalement donc on va y aller
pour 1,50 milliard je serais pas surpris
gerald convoi même revise et à la hausse
ce montant-là au cours des prochains
mois puisque les deux sites de province
seront tracées à ces 50 milliards
d'obligations provinciales 10 milliards
donc c'est pour ça que c'est écrit 60
milliards en bas d'écran 10 milliards
d'obligations d'entreprises pourquoi on
fait ça mais ça aussi c'est du jamais vu
on ne s'harmonisent un peu avec qu'est
ce qu'on voit du côté de washington
quoi qu'on est moins agressif aux
cadeaux on parle semaine interventions
sur le marché secondaire et non pas de
marché plus loin c'est que les
entreprises et aussi qu'on a discuté
emprunté à date ne pouvait y aller ce
marché - terme à ce marché obligataire
les entreprises c'est quand même mille
milliards de dette
il ya beaucoup de d'entreprises dont des
dates viennent à échéance et c'était
sont pas capables de renouveler donc on
vient
s'installer on vient offrir une certaine
garantie morale j'irai pour que c'est
une bonne entreprise est de bonne
qualité à ce soit pour les entreprises
avec des mauvais bilan il a brisé un bon
bilan vont pouvoir emprunter
sinon on augmenterait le nombre de
faillites au canada ottawa et énergie
encore l'accès à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence est ce que est ce
que vous considérez qu'il y avait des
incohérences
ben ouais bien sûr que sa bonne chose à
faire je m'explique faut garder aussi un
incitatif pour des gens qui veulent
travailler peut-être à temps partiel
parce que certains une situation que
voulait mieux toucher le 2000 pièces par
mois parce que tu travaillais à temps
partiel ben finalement pour dépanner à
les aider dans les chs b ou je ne sais
pas moins au niveau des épiceries bien
le super d'être après station grisonne
d'urgence donc une incitatif au travail
pour pouvoir mme et épauler les roues
olivo emplois à temps partiel tout en
ayant sur des 1000 dollars de dons
jusqu'à concurrence de 1000 $ comme vous
explique c'est la bonne chose à faire
parce que on avait un bel objectif et
s'amenait des dommages collatéraux sur
telle même entreprise avait des
difficultés à garder leurs employés à
temps partiel à cause de cette fameuse
procession canadienne d'urgence aussitôt
tous gagnants dollars belo tu perds des
prestations que donc on voit de
champeaux dogmatique il s'ajuste mais
s'ajuste régulièrement commencé depuis
trois semaines
un mot sur la réouverture de l'économie
on entend ça de plus en plus on sent que
monsieur trudeau et sur le frein est un
peu là dessus mais monsieur legault veut
accélérer on entend aux états unis et
ailleurs dans le monde
est-ce qu'il est trop tôt pour parler de
rouvrir l'économie payant mais là on va
voir si notre fédération quinzaine comme
des rations et décentralisé ou non parce
que la réalité où vous avez commencé
votre réponse parce qu'on vient du
climat on vous a perdu sa coupe et
recommencer votre réponse mais l'idée
c'est là qu'on va voir la fédération
canadienne celle et décentralisé ou non
parce que la réalité du québec n'est pas
la main que la réalité en saskatchewan
d'autant plus que ici les mesures
monsieur legault fait preuve de
leadership mais mesures de confinement
avant les autres provinces donc selon
moi allons aussi tranquillement on voit
du côté consubstantiel et mène on
s'organise allant à l'ontario sa volée
au nombre de co regarder du côté de
l'europe on s'inspire aussi en europe on
voit que le nombre de coups dit
num hélas ce moment là la pression est
plus lent dans certains comme amiens
recule donc on y va tranquille mince
comme c'est comme si on avait fermé
toutes les lumières de notre maison de
toutes les pièces et le comme dit le
docteur aubade à horacio c'est que on
augmente avec un gradateur d'europe une
rupture dont on y va et je pense qu'il
faut continuer dans ce sens là mais
c'est pas vrai d'un océan à l'autre
merci beaucoup clément gignac merci au
plaisir à voir